a aã ã o reconhecimento de fala acho que
disse o cantor no anel esferas que os
tipos grupo e é assim o um quadro de
pessoal de quem falou dar que seja muito
bem-vindo jamais com veridiana e seu
curso com toda a fazerem e os estragos
de que um jogo é foco em oz amo vocês
pediram pra eu juro que é o nosso of
obsession as notas da opção
bom pessoal estava junto ontem sustos e
e coisas do tipo nunca normais eu vou
mas quantas pessoas que recomendaram
extinção porque o início do vídeo
passado não andou sem jogos de terror e
este temos visto é um jogo bom portanto
eu vou confiar em nós existimos lugar
não é e função não acho que o andres
ganhar este jogo
[ __ ] lado é e pelo que isto me traz
pessoal eu vou confiar em você o graf ou
desde 10 muito gostoso para lá nós somos
minha mulher eu acho que sim houve que
uma boa hora está em nossa casa é o foro
vou falar mal estamos numa casa por
entendimento bem gostosa vejam este
gráfico está muito bom o leixão esta é
nossa feminino e é este sou eu
não definitivamente isso não sou eu sou
uma mulher cansou esta senhora está o
meu marido o johnny o álcool porque eu
tenho um bigode todas as pessoas têm um
bigshow óculos dizer mas demos um
protesto em funil e agora estou numa
cozinha como ervas medicinais do
dinheiro fácil mas o [ __ ]
o que aconteceu aqui eu só estava a
analisar e sugerir bacias da equipe a
isto porque o bicho suíço português
paulo bento encara porte como assim esta
casa está cheia de por norma liga volta
para normalizar a 2000 deus temos já
aprontada ou até que uma estátua do
nosso país vizinho
também rodas e não sei o que fazer eu
não sei se vou passar férias nesta casa
se eu moro aqui eu não saio vamos
investigar só há vários para o caen
chegamos na cozinha
eu quero comigo né tá com medo para isso
espera um frigorífico de tal figura
ataque o frigorífico órgão sobre greve
não afasta o público que não consigo ir
mishina malága solução não botou krav
maga o é o ibooks 25 de abril luta e que
os líderes de rússia e eu não percebo
vamos continuar a explorar até ontem era
tem uma máquina de fazer café não é é
uma chance que a fé o amor encontrei que
nunca fui bom tentava que já morreu ou
está fora de prazo a hitachi com o carro
atingiu mirante eu vou beber agora este
café
dois dias atrás a 1 já não saibam que eu
sei que você quer vai concentrar o chute
micro organismo chega para lá também
investigará o resto da casa ocupa uma
cadeira que ainda o que irá acionar um
demônio da carreira chega chega eu tenho
deixando uma coisa que eu não fumo não
mas agora a sério pessoal este parece
muito bom pois não só está coligado na
boa opção eu só não sei o que eu tenho
inclusive que será que é por aqui mesmo
em um canal no youtube uma caixa de
música tocando não é por um piano eo
palhaço sabem que vocês não são palhaços
essas caixas tudo bem e daqui com isso
eu não percebo o meu certo ponto 1
surround sound está um pouco a variável
não consigo perceber onde é que é ainda
que esta porta não anotadas a na série
meu deus eu não consigo perceber eu
total fone do ouvido não saibam é que
venço das curvas do focar não não é um
em um quarto da criança é que vai passar
o horror é o terror é iluminado gerente
calma calma calma eu sabia que era aqui
dentro é sempre dentro do quarto das
crianças
olha só o design de mangues dela por
acaso não foi isso mesmo que eu tinha um
tapete disse quando eu era mais pequeno
o time rondava os carros em cima de
tempo fx de petanca agora
o qq boca não explorar então o quarto da
criança e está muito escuro e eu devia
ter uma flecha haiti pois via ok eu já
entrei aqui não ainda que um som que
esses três eixos útil é que se vão
esquentar e as escolas com acesso à
internet estão lá o casal no oeste onde
funciona a pronta agora eu tenho um
boxer é esta é minha mão é isso mesmo
uma mulher caiu uma bailarina é uma
caixa de valor e na vaga de rai mouse
batente o programa music placar só que a
então estrela botão direito do rato é
pra abrir a caixa o uso de left mouse
back to black music box a entregar a
coroa bailarina um perfil de qualquer
coisa parece é que o inter ex-oasis
embora os símbolos a já percebi então
que era eu preciso ativar a caixa para
conseguir símbolo x nahla curva isso
caiu agora já não parece imune ons
eu acho que eu acho que sobre esta
desliga caixa e baixo demais né alguém
está por detrás destes cortinados não
percebeu que apareceu ea água entrou
aqui nesse quarto entrou que ok o
tamanho segunda por e transposto foi não
sei o que eu vou fazer eu tô
simplesmente i profunda mar eo fmi não
sabe o que vai acontecer qualquer coisa
ae o iphan estação x sozinho alguém já
andou nem que o iphan cozinho é
perguntar tudo vai cair agora é preciso
se dirigir não temos mais durinha vamos
dançar funk sozinho o mesmo paranormal é
um símbolo e juntos já pagaram os 1.000
jesus tinham já saiu preciso dos
símbolos frabre a porta aí isso perder
outro símbolo aqui dentro pois nem tocar
a música tocava a música vai valer nessa
primeira e faça um chão meu a eu preciso
encontrar outro símbolo de ficar aqui
sou eu e minha mãe
adorava isso não vai expulsar um imac o
tac encontrei encontrar jazz a saae
mesmo assim o leão e surpreendeu o
botafogo não paulo ninguém como esse mas
sobretudo minecraft o relato pixel exato
por livre escolha senão embora saiba que
saiba para onde é que eu entrei ali não
era do outro lado não toco se ver no
topo esperar que tudo neste quarto
aberta e olha olha o golo de pronto
tratar abrir a porta não de senhorio
assunto em um fundo e não está aqui já
sabia que o cinema luxo através da luz
não valoriza não há sendo assim toca
música em ais até agora precisa três
finais
é isso mesmo pessoal preciso três finais
bora bora lá procurando por ter mistura
à água tem que passar aqui e é por isso
que não disponham baixar né ai ai
ambiental e aura miguel juntar dinheiro
e susto o jovem não se muda vitalino
civil a exatamente pensava que eu devia
ao elefante estava a seguir ufam capital
na pressa importa onde eu sou o top eo
bicho tá bem tudo em um funk que deve
ter um o javi tá aqui embaixo eu só
agora fato se deu de burra vai te embora
a janela está aberta ao reino pela
janela pra cá outra vez passa por aqui
outra vez eu vou deixar aqui o sinal
calma a tocar a música meu espírito é
muito complexo e sutil taka apenas um
jogo como destaque um sinal qualquer
outra
é isso o que já possuímos a hilux hilux
e burnley 3214 de hoje 14 no brasil não
é o quintal de uma casa e eu vou fazer
agora nesta parte eu já saí o meu culpa
exclusiva de altura e fica só nisso qual
eu já sei agora não só tocar a
musiquinha capello precisa encontrar
quando se usa aqui é só um é só um ok o
talento já apanhei o bebê que deu tromba
não quer saber agora tanto barulho ea
mãe de uma menina é isso mesmo
alguma coisa me apanhou a vou te
confessar novo anel agora já agora já
tenha maquininha é e só que não começava
de novo o caipira além disso agora temos
que procurar em baixa a apanhar este
aqui o carro - nosso primeiro já é mais
um símbolo alguns na cozinha temos que
investigar estou aí ó tá aqui embaixo
ae o bicho
ae
o gol então o que é que tem bicho fica
embaixo assunto eu acho que eu tava lá
em cima tá ali outro símbolo para
apanhá-la da lei bishr conhecido como
funciona a calma calma bicho deixou eu
sou eu acho que a equipe era um dois
três quatro faltas cinco símbolo já é
isso nota-se cinco faltas investigar
anteriores tudo olha um símbolo já eu
acho que esta caixa atrair que o bicho
não é qualquer fato de que quatro fotos
4 que eu estou vendo aqui nada não a
[ __ ] nenhuma disse lula o ataque um
toque um ataque no final tem final tem
por volta de 30 os pessoal 3 já
encontramos um e já encontraram junto
aqui dentro destas aulas encontrado por
seu traje domingo do fumante como tico
tico tico santa cruz na área dos frangos
tem calma contigo tahkokallio vamos lá
para cima
ontem o símbolo o fundo já vi pela outro
tem que outro aí encontramos mais dois
já não a tem um trunfo que descobre que
eu sou eu tomo um fundo mil isto é
bizarro e domingo é bizarro ae
o novo não meu deus
é difícil a cair não eu não consigo ver
não faltam dois exatamente tocar então
vamos chamá-la para se manter lá em cima
havia um que eu apanhei você que é um
símbolo e isso vai apanhar um órgão até
foto no foco em selo só acredita que
dentro do quarto país mais junto ao
somar junto de ficar lá embaixo que não
há nada não ocorrer vamos trabalhar
falar pessoal vai devagar se vai ao
longe a também jovem já vi já vi já
vital iguaçu escada para a aacd que
desapareceu
aí foi substituído por seu pichei quando
chocou sobre o cenário é canalha
quando o socorro chegou a guayaquil é
muito ruim não é muito barulho até
chegamos a china aja uma esquadra
opinião uma espada
o aclamou o bicho demônios 2000
indignados valores de sacanagem mas à
noite já morreu morreu e se beijam
aproximar porque o bicho a dormir
sabendo é possível não só vamos ficar
por aqui com espírito de festa e não
sabe eu estou simplesmente brilhante
tatá sem estrelas cebs foi só dela eu
acho que foi curto e espero que esse
tipo continua a avançar o jogo star
investiu só deixa o vosso grande leque
neste vídeo para receber os fãs querem
ver mais quando o jogo sair mesmo que
não caíram [ __ ] se eu gostar mesmo é
isto que o fla que favorito fiquem mãe
da próxima